all right uh look at the cap space
that's available to the teams either
planned accordingly like the patriots or
the teams that just haven't been
spending all that much in rolling it
over like the jaguars the jets and the
cults but of the teams that that have
the most to spend what we're going to do
now is
say and predict which players general
managers should be tampering with based
upon this cap space let's start with the
jaguars coach over meyer gm trent bauke
73.6 million in cap space who peter
should they already be
discreetly on the phone with
i'm going to be really boring right here
mike i'm going to say johnny smith the
tight end uh from tennessee who i think
is on the verge of exploding into one of
the best tight ends in football he
already is very close to that but i
think he could be a top five tight end
and what you want to do with trevor
lawrence is you want to say we have a
big target with excellent hands and a
guy who can not only just troll the
intermediate part of the field he can
also get downfield
i really like johnny smith i think he'd
be a perfect guy for trevor lawrence and
the jaguars
you know i i'm fascinated by the extent
to which urban meyer is going to try to
round up some ohio state guys michael
thomas not going anywhere in new orleans
he's restructured his contract it would
have been too much to trade him anyway
from a cap-hit standpoint i'm fascinated
by the possibility that the cowboys may
part ways with ezekiel elliott i think
that's at least on the table now after
the dag contract could he make his way
to jacksonville but for now i'm going to
say joe tooney get get offensive linemen
build some some depth and some quality
around your quarterback in order to keep
your quarterback in one piece uh but but
yeah that's not all that sexy either but
you're getting the sexy pick with the
first overall draft selection and trevor
lawrence all right joe douglas of the
jets has 69.2 million in cap space who
should he be on the phone with peter
i want either joe tooney or i want kevin
zeitler i want you know last year what
joe douglas did is he scotch taped his
offensive line and it didn't work
and so now what i do if i'm joe douglas
is i'm getting a guy for three or four
years who i know i can plug and play
with
on a rebuilt offensive line presumably
with a new quarterback i've already got
makai bechten
at one of the tackles
i need to get two guys in free agency
this year who can help me create
uh a front that's going to basically
allow a quarterback to succeed
and mckay becton did indeed work out
well last year as a top 10 pick for the
jets douglas has been building from the
inside out which is smart but one guy on
the outside and you've got the money to
spend and you have a new quarterback
presumably if they go that route with
zach wilson i like juju smith schuster
as a guy that maybe they should be
talking to and seeing if they can get at
a reasonable contract not a huge
contract but a reasonable contract they
clearly need help at the receiver
position in new york the patriots and
bill belichick 68.5 million in cap space
although
somewhat less now that they've redone
the deal with cam newton are keeping him
around who who should belichick be
calling other than his own guys
i i would call kenny gallaudet to me if
i am bill belichick i look at an
absolutely weak part of my team
and i say the best guy out there to be
both a combination field stretcher
big time producer at wide receivers
kenny goliday
i'm gonna say nobody because that's the
way the patriots do things you're not
gonna pay anyone big money you're gonna
wait and you're gonna wait and you're
gonna go out and you're gonna get volume
you're gonna get quantity and hope that
the quantity collectively becomes
quality so
we've only seen it twice for the
patriots and i really don't see bill
belichick using a big chunk of that
money on one guy so there's no one to
tamper with at this point you just wait
and see how the market plays out and
then you go get the guys who are left
colts and gm chris baldwin he's going to
have carson wentz he's got 46.6 million
in cap space who should he be calling
peter
you know that is a re the the cults are
really interesting right now because i
don't think they have a position
on their team
that is in huge trouble right now i
think the depth they've built up has
been good but if i'm them
the one position that i really think i
could use
a big time addition
is safety and john johnson with the rams
last year look you know when brandon
staley left the rams last year
he one of the things he was a little bit
in mourning about is not being able to
work with john johnson anymore he had
the green dot on his helmet he was the
leader of in that defensive huddle and
he's only 25 years old pro football
focus is fifth rated safety in 2020
i think he would be great in
indianapolis at the back of that
secondary i'd at least be trying to get
trent williams
to come play left tackle for me with
anthony castanzo retiring there's talk
about quentin nelson kicking out the
left tackle i wouldn't want to move him
i want to keep him where he is peter and
uh i would i would be trying to get
trent williams although again it looks
like he's going to stay where he has
been for the past year in san francisco
with the 49ers last one duke tobin the
bengals director of player personnel
they've got 42.9 million in caps based
in the franchise quarterback where
should they be going
mike there's been a lot of talk that uh
the bengals sitting at number five in
the draft are going to take a franchise
left tackle
and
i'm not saying that's impossible but i
believe they're going to go hard in free
agency after at least one tackle and the
two best tackles now are daryl williams
of buffalo and alejandro villanueva the
steelers
my
strong suspicion is that one of those
two guys will end up on the bengals so
that they can now say to joe burrow
listen you're not gonna get beat up the
way you were last year
oh and they'd be sticking to the
steelers if they'd get villanueva who
became a star in pittsburgh and by all
appearances will be walking away as a
free agent they need help to keep joe
burrow healthy after the devastating
knee injury in 2020.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports